mais d'abord plus de 11 millions de
personnes menacées la sécheresse qui
frappe l'afrique de l'est prive les
populations d'eau et de nourriture
l'aide alimentaire et agricole promise
par les pays occidentaux est largement
insuffisante le kenya est
particulièrement touché plusieurs
dizaines d'enfants sont morts de faim
depuis le mois de décembre magali
forestiers cette femme craint pour la
vie de son bébé
cela fait plusieurs jours que beaucoup
de kenyane comme elles ne parviennent
plus à nourrir leurs enfants alors elles
viennent demander de l'aide dans ce
petit hôpital de brousse au nord-est du
kenya
cette femme est à bout de force
elles ne peuvent plus allaiter son
enfant qui présente des risques de
malnutrition depuis plus d'un mois des
dizaines d'enfants affamés sont
accueillis avec leurs parents à
l'hôpital de wajir aujourd'hui le centre
est saturé les médecins bien démuni face
à cette menace de famille qui tous ceux
qui ont pu arriver jusqu'à sont parfois
dans un état critique
ils font sont déjà maurice issil de les
nourrir m par intraveineuse monde ratée
conclue cb beaucoup de mal à les mains
sous perfusion tout fric de cette région
film pire sécheresse de son histoire
les bergers ont du troupeau il n'a plus
depuis décembre il n'y a donc pas eu de
récolte les quelques réserves d'eau sont
insuffisantes et soit propre à la
consommation l'onu lance un appel aux
dons d'urgence
il y a aujourd'hui deux millions et demi
personnes qui ont besoin d'une
assistance alimentaire cela correspond à
190 millions de dollars
il nous faut cet argent tout de suite
pour nourrir ces gens nous suivent
depuis décembre 40 personnes sont déjà
mortes au kenya alors pour éviter la
famine une aide massive doit arriver et
sans délai pour faire face au moins
jusqu'aux prochaines pluies prévues fin
mars